الصور التي تاتينا مباشره من اسطنبول
تحديدا حيث يشهد محيط بلديه اسطنبول
الكبرى تظاهرات دعت اليها المعارضه طبعا
رفضا لقرار سجن رئيس بلديه المدينه
المعارض اكرم امام اوغلو ومنعه من العمل
اسياد دي او سياسي بالاحرى وهنا يعني بانه
خلال هذه الفتره وحتى تنتهي عمليه استئناف
الحكم التي اكدها محاميه سيبقى في منصب
رئيس البلديه ولكنه بات مستبعدا من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقرره العام المقبل
طبعا هذه القضيه تعود الى تصريح صدر عنه
عن امام اوغلو بعد ما هزم مرشح حزب الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان في انتخابات العامه 2019
وهناك معروف عنه بانه معارض اولا كان من
المفترض ان يكون المرشح المعارض والذي س-
يدخل الانتخابات الرئاسيه لينافس الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
وتمت ادانته
باهانه مسؤولين وهو امر يمنعه عمليا من
ممارسه السياسه على كل من المزيد حول هذه
التظاهرات وهذه الوقفه ونتوقع في اي لحظه
ان تكون له كلمه معنى من اسطنبول مراسل
العربيه زيدان يقول له اهلا بك زيدان انقل
لنا همم
الاجواء التصريحات المظاهرات والشعارات
التي ترفع في هذه الوقفه الاحتجاجيه
نعم ميسون بعد قليل ستبدا فعاليه الرسميه
لهذا التجمع الرئيسي المعارضه التركيه على
مطربه مننا نحن نقف في منطقه قريبه من هذا
التجمع سنحاول ان نرصد لكم المشهد كما
شاهدناه قبل قليل طبعا زعماء او خمس زعماء
لاحزاب المعارضه باستثناء زعيم حزب
السعاده الذي
غاب عن هذا التجمع لوعكه صحيه لكن ارسل
مفادا عنه للمشاركه في هذا التجمع الذي
تعول عليه المعارضه في حشد تاييد شعبي
لشارع التركي ومؤيد ومؤيته همم اكثر منهم
رئيس بلديه اسطنبول لرفض هذا القرار طبعا
المعارضه من خلال او منذ صدور قرار
المحكمه يوم امس تعمل على مسارين المسار
الاول وهو حشد الشارع لاسيما الذين صوتوا
همم رئيس بلديه اسطنبول سواء كانوا من
جمهور احزاب المعارضه او حتى من جمهور حزب
العداله والتنميه هناك حشد في الشارع لرفض
قرار المحكمه التركيه الجانب الثاني الذي
تشتغل عليه المعارضه هو الشق القانوني اي
همم تقديم طعن كما اكد محامي همم اكرم
امام اوغلو يوم امس تقديم طعن بالقرار
الذي صدر بحق رئيس بلديه اسطنبول همم ومن
ثم متابعه هذا الطعام طبعا القرار لن يكون
نافذه القرار المحكمه همم سواء كان بالسجن
او الحضر من العمل السياسي الا بعد تصديق
محكمه الاستئناف همم التركيه والمحكمه
العليا على هذا القرار وبالتالي هذا
الموضوع يتطلب وقت ليس بالقليل من طبيعه
الحال يبقى الاجراءات القانونيه المتبعه
هنا في تركيا لكن بكل الاحوال همم
لدى المعارضه لتجنب
فقط اا اود الاشاره كنا ننقل مباشره الصور
من حيث التجمع الان تبدا هذه الكلمه طبعا
لاكرم ايمان اوغلو وهو رئيس بلديه اسطنبول
همم اتفضل زيدان
الشرق القانون المهم جدا لدى
المعارضه التركيه هم يعلمون تماما ان
القرار هو السياسي بامتياز او اهداف
القرار تابعات القرار السياسيه لكن الشق
القانون لا تريد المعارضه ان تقفل هذا
الجانب بذلك همم ستعمل بكل ما امكنها في
كل الطرق القانونيه للطعام بهذا القرار
ومن ثم محاوله الغائه او تعديل القرار او
يعني همم القرار بشكل كامل او تخفيف همم
حدث هذا القرار همم وهذا ما ستكشفه الايام
القادمه من الاجراء موضوع المعارضه
التركيه زيدان ذكرت انه هذا الموضوع بياخذ
وقت هل يمكن همم ان همم ان يمتد الى ما
بعد الانتخابات
لا شك ان الفريق القانوني الذي يعمل على
القضيه رجح ان هذا الموضوع ربما ياخذ اكثر
من عام ل همم البث بشكل نهائي فيه
وبالتالي همم
مضي- وقت الانتخابات لكن بالعموم يعني
بموضوع الترشح اكثر منهم الى منصب الرئاسه
هذا الموضوع كان مستبعدا حتى قبل هذا
القرار المرشح الاكثر همم ترجيحا لدى
المرض التركيه هو زعيم المعارضه نفسه كمال
ولكن لا شك ان هذا القرار سيصب في مصلحه
الحملات الانتخابيه سواء لكمال اوغلو
لتعزيز موقفه في الشارع او حتى لدى احزاب
المعارضه الاخرى التي كانت تشكك بشعبيه
زعيم المعارضه على حساب شعبيه اكرم امام
بلو الذي كان اطرافنا المعارضه والتحديدا
نتحدثون عن حزب الخير وزعيم حزب الخير
ميرا الاكشنر التي كانت ترجح ترشيح اكثر
من امام اوبر رئيس اسطنبول او من سوريا
رئيس بلديه انقره لكن زعيم المعارضه
التركيه هو الاكثر حذوه في الترشح
منصب الرئاسه في مواجهه الرئيس الحالي رجب
طيب اردوغان ولكن بالمقابل ايضا بحال لم
يستطيعوا ولم
يجر فبالتالي رئاسه البلديه بتلك الحاله
تعود الى منافسه وهو من الحزب الحاكم هذا
ما فهمته
القرار وتم حظر
اكرم امام اوغلو من العمل السياسي سيعود
الموضوع الى المجلس البلدي في بلديه
اسطنبول وهذا المجلس البلدي تسيطر او
يسيطر عليه غالبيه الاعضاء المنتخبين فيه
هم الحزب العداله والتنميه وبالتالي
تلقائيا سيعود مقعد بهذه اسطنبول او رئاسه
بهذه الاسطنبول الى الحزب الحاكم
شكرا جزيلا
ويديرمان